I actually grew up in Lake Forest
California and South Orange County yeah
actually came to LA to go to rehab and I
was in rehab there in East LA and then I
was sober for three years and then I
relapsed when my grandfather died and I
had met somebody out here and his mother
is actually out here on Skid Row and
when I relapsed we came and visit her
and kind of just got stuck down here so
that was about three years ago heroin
and meth and now I'm on fentanyl too so
I started using drugs at like 13 and I
partied a lot and was just progressing
to the next radnyx jug and eventually I
was sitting in my best friend's house
with her mom who she was smoking heroin
and I was already I met and I seen her
mom and I asked her mom for a hit and
her mom gave me it and from there on I
just became out of control with my
heroin habit yeah you know actually I
was adopted at the age of six at two
years old I was taken from my mom's
custody she had been with a guy who was
an alcoholic addicted to crystal and he
would physically abused me really bad
like step on me like almost like almost
borderline torture when I was taking the
day is taken from her custody he had
stepped on my head and he had an imprint
and pretty not not just on my skin but
on my my skull the bottom of his
timberland boots and so I was taken from
my mom's custody and it was a long
custody battle I was in group home
foster homes eventually my mom's aunt
and uncle were able to take me in and it
was like a fairy tale like family like
it was for kids two boys two girls and
Orange County with a beautiful home and
had the green grass and the pets and
everything the mom the dad and it was
like any child would want to be adopted
into that family but a month after I was
adopted my so-called father adoptive
father had left he left my mom five kids
she was a stay-at-home mom he just up
and left and she had to go from being
sterile mom to provide him for all of us
you know and I love my mom for that
because she did it you know like you
know that's my adopted mom yeah she she
didn't let that stop her from raising
her kids you know she went to work she
provided for us we were continued able
to continue to stay in that that Orange
County lifestyle you know I can't say
that we were spoiled but we had
everything we needed and now that I'm
older and I look back man like we lived
on a lake and my mom was able to do that
you know like it wasn't easy for her but
she was able to do it and I respect her
so much now for that you know
but unfortunately for whatever reason
I'm the only one out of all kids to end
up on drugs like I am you know
mm I don't know I feel like it was
always around like just with a group of
kids that I was around I wasn't around
with the popular kids I've seen out the
stoners you know like it just the
culture of drugs was always around me
and I glamorized it like heroin
addiction in my life but my mind was
glamorized it was like a beautiful
tragedy like almost every girl I knew
wanted to be that that dope fiend girl
for whatever reason cuz she always got
saved her you know like so it was always
glamorized in my head in my life but
it's not so glamorous you know like it
it is hard you know like Skid Row in
taxi no actually I don't do that I don't
know I think it's God or whatever i i i
will hustle i will sell things i will
sell i sell dope i yeah i - cuz i am
messed up as it's now i'm good at
something do i sell heroin I sell
crystal itself and all but it's hard to
be a female out here cuz none of these
dope dealers they're all gang members
men they don't want to see a female up
do that like cuz any person out here
would rather buy drugs from a pretty
looking girl than a hardcore gang and so
I get you know like math it's hard for
me to make any money out here selling
dope because they don't want to see me
make it you know the crazy thing is out
here I came out here with my my
boyfriend at the time
and me and him ended up breaking up
he turned gay on me and I met somebody
else and I never thought I would fall in
love with somebody on Skid Row
but he's the only person in my life
that's ever tried to get me off drugs
you know Anna even my family left me out
here for dead I hate my family I don't
want nothing to have to do with this
because I never hurt them I never Rob
through them I never stole for them but
they left me out here and when I asked
them for help no I know I said many
other ask me for anything
I asked them for a program you know what
to get me out of here they denied me of
that but this this man who was a
hardcore gang member a killer who who
who has no heart is the only man that's
ever offered to help me get out of this
and a lot of people have the wrong
conception of people out here when I
first came out here I was so judgmental
I was like [ __ ] living in a tent [ __ ]
dude I'm asleep in my car when I lost my
car I had to stay in a tent but now my
family that I choose to have my family
are these people out here that I met my
sister's not my sister and my family
because I don't
those are my family but my sister out
here she's the only one that's ever
encouraged me to keep going and keep
doing better you know and uh it's weird
because my whole outlook on life has
changed to being out here I don't want
to die out here I don't want to be
another girl found in a tent burned
alive
you know I've had one of my closest
homeboys die in a tent go into the
coroner's office as a John Doe and I
don't want that to be me and my family
they don't know where I'm at
they don't know if I'm alive and I don't
care because they don't care to find out
I have a facebook they can find me
but these people knew that I'm now
choosing to make my family they check on
me every day they make sure I'm okay
they make sure I'm fed clothed healthy
my my boyfriend now
he cuz I had an eating disorder ik I
wouldn't eat he makes sure I eat every
day and as little things like that that
people don't no matter to somebody but
they matter you know and I've had my
heart changed for people out here
because I'm one of these people out here
I never thought I'd be somebody to live
on Skid Row but I can say that I stay on
Skid Row but it gave me a heart a heart
that I never had Oh heart to care for
somebody that nobody wants to care for
my mom my my my ex-boyfriends mom who's
been out here since she was 15 years old
she's has HIV and lung cancer and she's
dying nobody checks on her nobody feeds
her all they do is feed her crack one
day I'm gonna find her dead in her tent
I know I am and what is anybody gonna do
about people are dying out here every
day and it's like what is it what is
anybody doing about it I'm just one girl
stuck up here I try to make it home I I
don't know what my next step is but I
don't I'm not gonna be out here forever
I'm 25 years old and I don't I don't
want to stay stuck out
some of my closest friends are those
people that talked about how they were
gang members and murderers and my best
friend she's been a prostitute since she
was 14 years old but I love her because
she's real and she has a heart I always
thought I was better than everybody
because I was from Orange County because
I grew up in a good lifestyle a good
home but I'm not better than nobody I'm
I'm just as just as low as everybody
else and okay
I'm okay with that because when you're
at your lowest point is where you get
your greatest strength and my next move
in my life
you boy gonna be shocked because I've
set in my heart my next steps you know
these three things to keep secrets are
you your your finances your love life
and your next move and my next move is
gonna be my greatest move and my life
isn't gonna be nothing what it is now
I'm gonna make sure because nobody else
kit but me you know I know I miss my
family everyday and it hurts me but [ __ ]
them because they didn't care if I was
alive or not every single one of my
siblings have gotten married and I'm
never gonna be in one of those wedding
books and I'm okay with that
because they're not gonna be in mine
either
you know and it's kind of like a harsh
thing to hear to say but it's really how
I feel you know because I never wronged
them I never did them in the wrong but
they cheated me like I did and that hurt
and it's just it's everyday I wake up
but I see where I'm at
and there's a harsh reality of what I
chose to do with my life I haven't done
anything I've not graduated high school
I have not accomplished anything in my
life but that doesn't mean my life is
over I don't know very much I've not
been very many places but I'm about to
live a life that I could never imagine
because I'm gonna choose that I'm not a
mom I'm not a wife a wife or whatever
it's just me myself and I and I'm gonna
make sure that that one day when I do
become a mom that I'm gonna be the
greatest moment because I never had that
that I'm gonna make my children
there's a harsh reality out here when
you see your friends die we can see the
people around you strung out the people
you love the most
so hurt but all you can do is try to be
a light for them even when you need
someone to be a light for you
think